okay someone knows samuel is this and
sometimes people honestly think
just because it's coronavirus going
around
just because it's new year's eve they
genuinely think
what i'm not gonna just drive to their
house
or what guess what it's new year's eve
right now the last day of 2020
i'm driving to your house people think
people think i wouldn't do this
you know i mean honestly when people
order books and stuff from my website
what time i get people ordering ordering
my books ordering my books
all the while someone has got to be the
postman
i'm leaving the house but this is work
like
someone has to be the postman so right
now there's a couple people
that won the prize draw from yesterday
after the eviction uh a couple people so
what i'm going to do right now
i'm going to drive to their house they
have no idea that i'm coming
drive to their house and uh tell them
that they want a load of free stuff so
this is work this is the last day of
2020
tomorrow's 2021 happy new year everybody
let's go i've got to go turn up with
some people's houses this is gonna be
fun
let's go
[Music]
it's been a pretty smooth drive we're
currently five minutes away from their
house
and they have to be at home i mean on
new year's eve
with the current covert restrictions i'm
kind of relying on them being at home
but let's find out i think we're
basically almost here
sadie and ross i got these parcels for
you
i've got your books i got your parcels
let's do this let me find this house you
think i won't come to your house
i'll come to your house i'll find it
i'll find your house so i'm finding your
house
upstairs i'm coming for you
you really think i won't come to your
house
i told you i'll come to your house
get the faces hey what's happening
hi respect i told you i'd come to your
house
yeah is it um ross holly
ross
however here are your parcels
i didn't believe it honestly yeah yeah
so uh massive respect thank you so
welcome
for winning it was a proper random pick
and i'm really glad that you guys won it
all right winners wednesday 2021
hopefully yeah
well done guys see you all soon you'll
probably see them on winners on a
wednesday but let me tell you something
if you want to become financially free
if you want to get trained in property
so how to make 2021 a year unlike any
other year
then i would like to invite you to join
me at the property investors crash
course guess what
it's an incredible training program tens
of thousands of people before
and it's completely free so join me for
free
the 9th of january i'll put in the
description i'll put a little link
there's a one pound booking fee just to
check that you're a real person
and you're going to let everything i've
learned about property over the last 12
years
in one day on the virtual property
investors crash course it's virtual but
it feels like a real event
you really need to be there get booked
on that's my gift for you
on this new year's eve happy new year
i'll see you at the crash course
get booked on peace out
[Music]